used to be laid back Carefree not a  worry in the world now every White Guy  meets us so obsessed with look at  open-minded Progressive it's taking over  the whole identity we used to have a  devil and an angel on our shoulder  helped us make decisions now we have a  racist and an HR person  a black guy African-American person of  color I love lizzo please take a photo  with me Obama  oh it's embarrassing and everybody  thinks white people of all this pride  and Supremacy he's like what are you  kidding every white guy knows on 23andMe  and ancestor.com going come on Native  American come on baby Latino lesbian  something yeah  have you noticed how hard we white guys  gotta let you know he's a victim now in  some way he's got a hook an angle a  gimmick he can't just be white anymore  you gotta have a thing sure I'm white  but hey I'm on the Spectrum